uh
so again from an evolutionary
computation perspective
we'll look at all the agents that had to
die
in order to come up with different
solutions in simulation
uh what do you think from that
individual agent's perspective is the
meaning of it all
so far as humans you're just one agent
who's going to be dead
unfortunately one day too soon
what do you think is the why
of why that agent came to be
and uh eventually will be no more
is there meaning to it all yeah in
evolution there is meaning everything is
a
potential direction everything is a
potential stepping stone
um not all of them are going to work out
some of them are foundations for further
improvement and even those that are
perhaps
going to die out uh where potential
energy is potential solutions
in biology we see a lot of species die
off naturally and you know like the
dinosaurs i mean they have a really good
solution for a while
but then it didn't turned out to be not
such a
good solution in the long term uh when
there's an environmental change
you have to have diversity some other
solutions become better
it doesn't mean that that there was an
attempt it didn't quite work out or last
but there they're still dinosaurs and
mountains at least they're relatives
uh and they may one day again be useful
who knows uh so from an individual's
perspective you've got to think of a
bigger picture
that it is a a huge engine
that is innovative and these elements
are all
part of it potentially innovations on
their own and also as
as raw material perhaps or
stepping stones for other things that
could come after but it still feels from
an individual perspective that i
i matter a lot but even if i'm just a
little coggin in the giant machine
well is that just a silly human notion
in uh individualistic society you know
she'll let go of that
do you find beauty in being part of the
giant machine
yeah i think it's meaningful um i think
it adds
purpose to your life that you are part
of something bigger
that said are you uh do you ponder your
individual agent's mortality do you do
you think about death
do you fear death well
certainly more now than when i was a
youngster and did skydiving and
paragliding and
you know all these things you've become
wiser
um there is a reason
for this uh life arc that
younger folks are more fearless in many
ways it's part of the exploration
you know they are the they are the
individuals who think hmm
i wonder what's over those mountains or
what if i go really far in that ocean
what would i find
i mean older folks i don't necessarily
think that way
but younger do and it's kind of
counter-intuitive so yeah
it's this uh and biologically it's like
you know you have limited amount of time
what can you do with it that matters
right so you try to you have done your
exploration you
committed to a certain direction and you
become an expert perhaps in it
what can i do that matters uh with with
the
limited resources that i have that's
what how you i think
a lot of people myself included start
thinking later on in their career
and uh like you said leave a bit of a
trace and a bit of an impact even though
after the agent is gone yeah
that's the goal well this was a
fascinating conversation i don't think
there's a better way to end it
thank you so much so first of all i'm
very inspired of how vibrant the
community at ut
austin in austin is it's really exciting
for me
uh to see it and this whole field
seems like profound philosophically but
also the path forward for
the artificial intelligence community so
thank you so much for explaining so many
cool things to me today
and for wasting all of your valuable
time with me oh it was a pleasure
thanks i appreciate it
you